ah the mystery genre so renowned yet so
underrated by the general public it's
really a niche genre with a few big hits
here and there but when you ask a random
fan about mystery anime recommendations
you'll probably not get a lot of
variances i mean that's understandable
and that's why i'm here today
you know i really enjoyed these decade
in review videos i've been slowly
introducing so let's kill two birds with
one stone here shall we today i'll be
presenting another decade in review
video and our topic will be mystery
anime i hope this will serve as a way
for me to recommend some shows or movies
that you might want to check out while
the focus will be on what i think is the
best and or most accessible shows in the
year i'll also be doing some niche shows
as honourable mentions so that you can
find some hidden gems along the way
because trust me the mystery genre does
have a sizeable amount of those ready to
kick off the show and start solving
clues and mysteries sherlock then let's
get started
2011
we have a great start to the decade some
may argue that the start is actually
2010 and i should be starting around
there but i want to end in 2021 and i
think the starting from 2011 would make
ending in 2021 more proper it's also
funny that i just opened with a
time-based rambling because our pick for
2011 has lots and lots of time
shenanigans you guessed it stein's gate
is our first winner being my top mystery
anime of 2011. i don't think any more
needs to be said about stein's gate it's
the show that puts studio white fox on
the map and it's one of the most
critically acclaimed series of all time
i love the time travel shenanigans yes
but i personally love the twist being
there to speculate and uncover mysteries
throughout the whole ride couple that
with some extremely memorable characters
starring everyone's favorite chuni mad
scientist
scientist is so cool
i wouldn't say that the competition is
anywhere as tough here as you'd expect
actually i personally love the hell out
of go seek and even had a video on that
on my other channel so do check that one
out while i mostly classify it as edgy
action future diary also has some
elements of mystery in it as well and if
the violent death battles aren't your
thing perhaps the questions about
humanity that the show throws at you can
get you to like it if you're up for some
mind screw though penguin drum could be
something to tickle your fancy
2012
2012 is a year of intrigue what with
that supposed ending of the world
looming on the horizon and all of that
stuff do you remember that in the anime
community's case 2012 is when people
were focused on blockbusters like
psychopaths jojo and sao as well as the
epic finale of fate zero as expected the
mystery shows played second fiddle to
the mainstream action ones that's quite
unfortunate though if i must say because
2012 also brought in a healthy selection
of titles that would let you exercise
your brain muscles a little bit yoka is
one yoga is one of my favorite shows
from this year and i absolutely love the
dynamic between the main cast heck i
like the show so much i even watched
other adaptations of it like the live
action movie however putting my bias
aside i'd have to give this year's award
to from the new world known in japanese
as shinsekai yori from the new world is
such an underrated and unappreciated
show i know that it now has quite a
polarizing reputation in some parts of
the community but it was such an amazing
journey back then following it weekly
really gave me a whole different
experience and the experience of
speculating and discussing it was
extremely enjoyable from the new world
also takes its time to thoroughly
develop its questions philosophies and
world which in a twist in the dystopia
genre doesn't take place in a super
high-tech world if you've been around
this time you could have seen pics of an
eye patch girl and some edgy scenes
related to it that show is called
another it's quite the mature mystery
that will keep you craving for more
answers with each passing week and you
should definitely give that one a try
too
2013
compared to 2012 2013 was sadly a pretty
weak year for mystery anime while i
won't say that it's weak in the quality
sense a lot of this year's mysteries end
up being me [ __ ] even less popular than
the supposed niche hits i mentioned in
the previous entries for one i don't
exactly know a lot of people who watched
carnival with its whimsical and elegant
atmosphere of a circus mystery magical
fantasy comes together with intrigue to
form an underrated mystery show devils
and realist also went with a victorian
era theme a lot of pretty boys and quite
the unique setting and premise involving
the supernatural and the occult it's
something girls would love but guys can
also enjoy so in a year that's quite
thin in terms of mystery anime what's my
pick well attack on titan now i've spent
quite a lot of time raving about attack
on titan already and that's just how
good it is it juggles its different
genres mystery being one of them so
seamlessly on route to creating a
cultural phenomenon of its own many
people back then were drawn into attack
on titan because of the action the lack
of fan service and the engaging and
cynical world that you don't often see
in anime however it also litters those
scenes with an ever going mystery that
keeps the viewers asking more what are
the titans actually remember the memes
about the basement those are just the
tip of the iceberg for 2013's mystery
anime of the year
2014.
i mention movies in the intro remember
it's because 2014 is where my first
movie recommendation comes into play and
i'd love to introduce you to when marnie
was there based off the classic
children's novel when marnie was there
it shows off she believes chops when it
comes to adapting foreign material and
doing it justice the movie may seem to
be your typical artistic dramatic film
at first but seeing how the mysteries
unravel as you ponder the plot and the
character interactions makes for such a
fun time tokyo ghoul which came quite
close to winning my action anime of 2014
on my previous list was also rife with
questions i doubt that many people watch
it for the mystery however as it's
primarily known for being the action
series with a super catchy opening that
has since been immortalized speaking of
edgy that brings me to my pick for this
year terror in resonance yep you've got
the terrorists the conspiracies and the
cat and mouse chase terror in resonance
is a thriller that just doesn't let go
from the strong opening you get immersed
into a show that will keep you on the
edge of your seats it's also quite
refreshing to watch a show that's told
from the supposed antagonist side and
you spend each episode theorizing about
sphinx's backstories their motives and
when their luck will finally run out you
can't outrun fate are you sure a cell
can make a spectacle after trying to do
so an explosive one even
2015
yet another decently strong year for
mystery anime 2015 brought us charlotte
it's somewhere in the mid tier as far as
pa works anime goes but it became quite
popular in its time i enjoyed it and i
had fun watching the characters and
forming my own theories on the mysteries
the show lays out but i've yet to see if
it's aged well throughout the years all
i know is that despite its popularity it
was quite polarizing oh and speaking of
polarizing 2015 is the year of rocker
braves of the six flowers it has one of
the more interesting setups for a
mystery anime although some might say
that it looks to be more tailored for an
action series oh and there's school live
as well with this deceptively cute
aesthetics masking a horror mystery that
drew quite some buzz in the community
since day one however what i feel is the
best mystery anime of 2015 is
death parade the concept of life after
death has always enchanted me to see it
presented as a game room was definitely
a new concept for me it also surprised
me with how much it captivated me with
each episode in each new case the art
also looks unique for the medium and it
certainly helps the show stand out
amongst its peers i never had a dull
moment watching death parade so i give
it the win for 2015.
before we continue if you find yourself
enjoying the video i'd like to ask for
your subscription
it doesn't take long and it will do a
lot to spread the word and help my
channel grow you may also ring the bell
so that you can get notifications as
soon as possible now you're going to
want that so you can be first in line to
see the next decade in review video
that's right there's going to be more
2016.
i found 2016 to be one of my favorite
years after all it's when arjin one of
my favorite thrillers was unleashed to
the world i really like the idea of an
us against the world story layered with
multiple questions about its world and
the origin of the arjun if you're
looking for more traditional action
boongo stray dogs maybe 2016's show for
you battle shows a mystery aren't the
most common combination out there but
boy did the series make it work really
well in between the problem solving
there are lots of epic fights erased
also debuted here it quickly took the
anime world by storm not to the same
degree that the most renowned hard
hitters did but it was one of the show
that did cliffhangers the best i found
myself binging more than half the series
in one go fueled by my own questions and
how much i wanted to see the conclusion
to the budding relationship between
satoru and kaio as for that said
conclusion well
there's a reason array's last stretch
was quite controversial often in
hilarious meme forms you know what other
mystery show did take the anime world by
storm as a smash it one involving time
loops two re-zero did and it's my pick
for 2016's top mystery series it's a
really close battle between that and
erased and ultimately i give re-zero the
nod primarily an isakai and a thriller
re zero builds most of its intrigue by
shooting us into a world full of
questions that need to be answered
what's the nature of subaru's loops
what's rosewall really like what's
amelia's relation to the witches as a
series it thrives on building suspicion
and slowly lifting the veil one painful
loop at a time
this gives the show such an engaging
narrative that i just couldn't get
enough of the anime fans seem to agree
as re zero has quickly become one of the
most beloved and popular isakai series
of them all
2017.
coming off the high of the 2016 season
my expectations were sky high for 2017.
for the most part i wasn't disappointed
because 2017 gave us some of the most
unique and renowned mystery anime in
recent memory in quick enumeration we
have acca princess principal land of the
lustrous and girls last tour with such a
wide selection you get your fair share
of politics action and sci-fi scattered
amongst the mentioned shows however
there's one mystery anime this year that
stands above the lot of them and that's
the critically acclaimed made in abyss
what i absolutely love about made in
abyss is that it's pretty much got the
best of all worlds character dynamics an
absolutely enthralling world waiting to
be explored beautifully drawn
backgrounds and the ability to shift
seamlessly from light-hearted to serious
the series has it all if you're someone
who's quite used to anime and the
general ins and outs of the medium this
is a show that i can readily recommend
as the good far outweighs the possibly
questionable content in it i won't call
it an adventure story that can be
enjoyed by the entire family but if
you're up for a thrilling journey
complete with an emotional rollercoaster
that can be as dark and batshit crazy as
anime goes then you are in luck made in
abyss is my pick for this year and i
think it will be yours too
2018.
unfortunately 2018 happened to be quite
a thin year for mystery anime relatively
speaking it's not that there's an
absolute shortage of mystery shows
however i don't have a lot of memorable
ones that i've seen especially when put
against the year we just had 2017.
experience only tells part of the story
and i'd like your help to give me some
suggestions for non-sequel mystery anime
series or films that began in 2018.
however though it isn't all doom and
gloom before the upcoming uzumaki junji
ito collection aired this year providing
the much-awaited grotesque horror edge
that the mystery anime i've talked about
have mostly lacked this one is more of a
pure horror thing compared to something
like tokyo ghoul after all i also
enjoyed be the beginning from this year
i'm always down for psychological
thrillers and had a good time watching
this vigilante series that surprisingly
provides a lot of interesting nuggets
about morals corruption and loyalty for
this year though i give the crown to a
chinese anime modal sushi those of you
into live action would have probably
heard of the series through the hit
drama the untamed but the anime
adaptation i'd say provides a really
great adaptation of the popular web
novel as well taking us to an ancient
world of dark arts and magic modauzushi
gives us a healthy dose of fights drama
and adventure as our two main characters
move to unravel the mysteries of the
spiritual world
2019
for me 2019's notable for one show my
pick for 2019's mystery anime of the
year is the horror thriller show the
promised neverland it truly set the bar
for excellence in horror and suspense
and it's amazing because the main source
of the horror is not even the demons
they come in the form of the sound
direction presentation the camera cuts
and all of that sort of stuff the
promise neverland first season is a
masterclass on how to present horror
anime that will keep the audience on the
edge of the seat about season two though
well we're not going to talk about that
the promise neverland easily won my pick
for this year but i can't help but
regret to say that it didn't have much
competition for the year 2019 is when
the movie hello world was screened as
well it's pretty much inception as an
anime with a story that weaves an ample
share of mystery and romance in a sci-fi
backdrop the other contender i had in
mind was another sci-fi show this one is
astra lost in space it's an anime that
took a while to get revved up and it's
positively one of the best examples of a
show that linearly got better with each
episode if only it didn't have that slow
start it would have definitely
challenged promise neverland could have
2020
ironically in a year rife with delays
and blockbuster sequels mystery anime
managed to get relatively a lot of
representation there are numerous
contenders in 2020 most of them imbued
with either psychological drama or
action series the action part is more
emphasized in tower of god which for me
is the best among the three webtoon
adaptations that we got it's a shame it
didn't have more episodes as i would
have loved to watch more of it also in
the same category is one of the most
engaging shows based off the classic
sherlock holmes setting moriarty the
patriot if you need to watch a home
setting story and have to pick among the
dozen of them this is my recommendation
comparatively i can see that the mystery
is more emphasized in talentless nana
among us the anime if you were to
describe it in a nutshell it's another
of those shows that i wish had more
episodes as way crazy as stuff happens
in the manga after where the anime ended
but my pick for this year it's none of
those actually as i award the title to
id invaded at its core it's a pretty
nice sci-fi mystery that could have
pretended to be a serious live-action
crime drama it also has a lot of
well-written characters that avoid or
subvert the usual tropes that you see in
the medium so yeah stop calling it a
poor man's derivative of psychopaths and
give id invaded a shot it's definitely
going to be worth your time 2021
if you've been listening to a lot of
antitubers these days no doubt you've
heard of the name or taxi people can't
stop talking about it and a lot of them
are pretty much getting ready to hand
the anime of the year title 2 or taxi do
you think that it deserves anime of the
year i mean i'm personally not as ready
to crowd it just yet but it does make
for a very strong case which is why
despite having one more season to go i'm
pretty confident that odd taxi is going
to retain its crown of being 2021's
mystery anime of the year what makes odd
taxi so unique is how deceptively simple
it seems honestly i feel that any random
passerby seeing the poster would
probably not feel as inclined to go for
it it's a show whose viewership seems to
be carried by word of mouth but really
it does deserve all the praise it's
deceptively simple and light but what
you'll get from one taxi is a very
immersive set of mysteries that just
keep building aided by the strong
writing you won't get bored as each
character has their own story to tell
and a contribution to the grand finale
that everything is building up to as for
other contenders i'd give them to kimono
gn sony boy and the chinese anime link
click they're great anime in their own
ways but i don't think that they come
anywhere close to our taxi if we were to
look at them as purely mysteries kimono
gn does have the stronger mass appeal
factor but it falls just a bit short
compared to odd taxi almost everywhere
else
that more or less wraps it up so how did
my list compare with yours if you like
watching the video and want to support
the channel in a more direct method you
might want to consider my patreon or
channel membership options they each
come with their own perks that i
guarantee that you're going to enjoy
overall it's been a fun experience
recapping the best of the decade through
this list i had tons of fun and i'm
hoping that you did too hope to see you
again in the next video until next time
[Music]
you